well go on take the bloody bag off his  head fresh start  introductions are Jay Galle our guest of  honor little monkey his name I still  don't know and I have Cork's him pagan  myth there are some very disreputable  people around those [ __ ] terrorists  in ruin everything look to my example  you'll see it as the positive influence  it is and they say I've lost touch with  my subjects  I'm with RJ golly  help  thanks for help you cry for help oh you  mean it boy from your diaphragm nothing  you afraid they're not coming for you  buddy  pre-order now for a free upgrade to the  limited edition includes three extra  story missions and a bonus Impaler  harpoon gun pre-order now Far Cry 4  available November 18 2014